Being an entrepreneur is obviously
an intimidating and daunting job.
What has been your biggest challenge so far?
My biggest challenge has been getting the word out.
I don't have really any advertising,
so it's just been word of mouth.
And I started with a Facebook page.
That's all, but I want to be able to get that word out,
get those new customers in, and keep them in.
Just like I've got all my loyal customers,
but also utilizing my time wisely,
making sure that I can get those cheesecakes out,
making sure that the the process is streamlined,
one right after another.
I'm making a list. Okay.
First of all,
I think you should start a Facebook group
that is based in the love of cheesecakes.
I don't care if there's one person that joins
or a hundred and anything in between.
There are probably other like-minded
cheesecake lovers out there.
Not only is it just fun to talk
to somebody about the thing you love most,
but it continues that word of mouth.
Sure.
Number two, I noticed you did not have an Instagram.
No.
Do you see my face?
(audience laughs)
So I went and just secured you an Instagram account
called "Oh for the Love of Cheesecake."
Good. Thank you.
It's all yours.
And we will have to switch an email afterwards,
but I just didn't want anybody to grab it
in the next few seconds
because this is gonna be a game changer for you.
Welcome to the whatever century this is.
(audience laughs) 21st.
And what I want you to do is I want you
to do an Instagram rabbit hole dive.
I would like you to not only find sites
that speak to you visually,
but I would like you to find sites
that do not speak to you,
because knowing what you don't want is as vital
as knowing what you do want.
So I want you to get really clear on that.
Okay.
Next, a logo.
I mocked up some inspiration logos,
and I went two different directions
'cause I kind of wanted you
to eyeball it and tell me
if like one was a visceral yes or no.
Will you take a look at these?
Yes, absolutely.
Okay, so here's sort of a modern, timeless, more circular,
very focused on the cheesecake slice itself.
And then I would like you to look
at this other logo that really hits the word more.
Did either one of those speak
to you or more importantly, not speak to you?
The one that has the negative space
did not speak to me,
but the one that had the "Oh" in the pie,
I like that one.
(audience laughs)
I actually saw your pupils dilate when you saw that.
And when I saw this, I was like,
oh, I'm really understanding the title
of your company better than I ever have.
And graphic treatment can really help tell
not only the story, but the cadence of the title.
This was something, I'm sorry, you overheard,
or you had a friend say?
What was the story behind your title?
I had a friend say it.
She took a bite of cheesecake and she went,
"Oh, for the love of cheesecake!"
And that was it.
That, it just stuck.
So yeah, the "Oh" is vital.
This is your cheesecake by the way.
Oh gosh.
Mm hmm (chuckles).
Oh, for the love of cheesecake.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, definitely quit your day job.
It's incredible.
It is incredible.
I've never had a piece of cheesecake,
and I think that was your triple chocolate layer,
that has that much of a prevalence
of chocolate and yet does not lose the essence
and the creaminess and the texture of cheesecake.
Well done. Oh my gosh.
Oh, for the love of cheesecake.
I think what they did with the "Oh" is very heavenly, too.
I'm so glad that you like it.
That means everything actually, because you believing
in it is going to make you want to go
to the mountain top and talk about it
on your new Instagram account and your new Facebook group.
Yay!
And also, we have another little surprise for you,
which is we want to give you $5,000
(audience applauds and cheers)
to use at your disposal, what you see fit.
I would reserve some of the money
to hire some help
because you cannot do this alone.
And if there's one reason that anything I have
ever done has worked
in any way, shape, or form,
it's because I chose to work with amazing people
and I never did anything alone.
I certainly will take that advice.
Well, I love that you are going out there
and showing people that we have one life.
This is not a dress rehearsal.
That is totally true.
And we only have so much time
to, I don't know if it's get it right
or just simply be happy, which is anything but simple.
I applaud you so much.
Thanks.
(audience applauds)
Finally. Thank you, Stephanie.
I have been dying to get back into this.
Good luck.
We'll be in touch.
I'd love to talk about this
and keep in touch with each other, okay?
Alright. Thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
Oh, for the love of cheesecake.
(upbeat music)